Since the days of Spanish conquerors 400 years ago wild horses have roamed
the western plains and man has set out to capture
and tame them ever since first the Indian and then
the cowboy a hoarse broken demands will helps in
his work or provide sport for his leisure
moments danger is in the air sense not seen
trouble from another source alone stallion joins
the herd to challenge the authority of the leader
the battle for supremacy is over but the
battle between man and beast has only begun
the horses are all from the Cowboys after them
the chase is on men on horses already trained
to the saddle against the wild for centuries
the horse has been a faithful service and Friends
of man but first he has to be captured and pain
their days of unbridled freedom come to an end
now he must learn to accept man's bidding
at first he fights the encroaching leather
with all the fierce pride of his birthright
a battle and then a man
but often it's harder on the man
since the dawn of time horses have roamed
the American continent but for some reason
buried in the past they vanished until the Spanish
explorers brought them back a new race came from
Spain and from Spain to came the noble lipizzans
the famous white stallions of the Spanish Riding
Academy unlike wild horses the lipizzans have
been bred for centuries for the specific purpose
of classical riding prancing through the
intricate steps of a quadrille on horseback
it's a far cry from wild horses of the
western plains the ancestors of these
lipizzans carry julius caesar into battle the
long relationship of man and beast covers many
moods many tasks at work or play some have
been bred and trained to saddle horses for
just a simple pleasure of riding or the more
exciting pursuit of following the hounds on a
fox hunt yikes and away and the gentry and
they're pink coats astride they're spirited
horses gallop across the fields and over the
fences in pursuit of Brer Fox it's sort of
an amateur steeplechase obstacles to clear
straightaway dashes hazards on every hand
the foxes at bay the hunt is over but there
is no end of thrills and horseback and to some
sportsman no frills so full of zest and speed
and dangerous polo here again the polo pony
has been bred for a purpose to be fleet of foot
and capable of responding to instant commands
the Persians train horses to play polo 4000
years ago the British brought the sport back
from India a century ago and as a result the
new sport was in the making sometimes it's rough
another specialist is the jumper
the keenest competition at horse
shows is among the cavalry and
again the horses are the product
of special breeding and training
the teamwork here reminds us of plans long
dependence upon the horse to
carry him over many obstacles
and thrill is piled upon thrill but
where would be the sport without the risk
as typically american as the hot dog is harness
racing it started in the United States where the
horse was schooled in the special gate that
distinguishes him from all other racers it
might be said that here the saddle is a sulky when
they bunch up at the turns trouble often results
with sulky and driver unceremoniously
dumped and trotters breaking stride
but training and instinct beat strongly and
a Trotter stays in the running the toughest
battle of all and the Waterloo for many horses is
the steeplechase one of terpenes most hazardous
events as many as 30 starters get away but only a
few will finish the toughest obstacles devised by
man and nature take their toll along the way
and one after another entries are eliminated
the ranks get thinner and another jump takes its
toll heartbreak and tragedy all
the rains for many a noble animal
now it is a race between four horses
or out of 30 that started and in the
last jump no writer to guide
him one horse takes a shortcut
the others battle it out in a stretch drive
yes trading and breeding have their say and
rich of the rewards for the winners the
sport of kings our race against time the
press of a button buy the starter sends
a field of bleat sprinters often running
in a test of speed and stamina all
fighting for a favorite position
crowd reacts to a pulsating drama of
thundering hoots it's not always the
favorite that wins it's the will in the way
of course--it rider as they travel to the
wire pounding down the stretch neck-and-neck
nose to nose in a fevered pitch of suspense
and excitement faithful and obedient at work
or at play the horse has truly served man well